round one Jason ozuma versus EO ozuma is
introduced and it becomes clear very
quickly that morawa has a deep deep
respect and adoration for black boxers
it's only natural given how Central
American boxing is to the boxing world
with famous fighters like Mike Tyson and
Sharay Leonard making headlines across
the globe consistently but the problem
is that well I think primarily as a
product of its time that reverence he
has for them Loops back around to being
offensive against again ozuma is talked
about as a natural fighter with talk of
his African-American Heritage giving him
a natural evolutionary Advantage how fun
and here I am waiting through a chapter
or two of awkwardness of 1989 morawa
waxing poetically about biological
advantages when all of a sudden out of
nowhere I am greeted by literal blackace
gag holy